let's talk about the upcoming critical
thinking series
should I tell that today I tell the
story from the beginning because some
people may not know we need a refresher
what's even going on by it by the way
Pat has no idea what I'm talking about
so I'll tell it just for his benefit at
least so Pat here's what's going on okay
we're working on a critical thinking
miniseries I have talked about for years
that the teaching of critical thinking
is very much lacking in the United
States it should really be taught by
sort of convention at the latest in high
school if not in junior high I believe
and at my class in the communication
department at Boston College that I
taught last fall I did a lot on critical
thinking as related specifically to
media literacy and epistemology but what
we're putting together is a 12 to 15
part miniseries that's taking notes now
so now he's gonna remember the story on
this a 12 to 15 part miniseries on
critical thinking which will include and
cover such issues as how to construct
arguments identifying good and bad
arguments the validity and soundness of
arguments identifying and examples of
logical fallacies etc etc etc this
initially was going to be funded through
patreon because we already produce a
daily show right so the idea was we want
to grow our patreon following which you
can read about at patreon.com slash
david pakman show you'll see we
currently have nineteen hundred and
eighty-three patrons initially we were
shooting for twenty two hundred and
fifty patrons at which point we would
produce and publish this critical
thinking miniseries we have since
secured two sponsors for the critical
thinking miniseries so you will notice
now if you go to patreon.com/scishow van
patten show that the critical thinking
miniseries goal has been reduced to 2100
patrons because since we now have the
series subsidized by these advertisers
we only need to get to 2,100 patrons we
are at 1983 right as of right now
meaning we are 117 patrons away from
2100 and we played last week for you an
example clip
on validity and soundness I've also
shown you that we have the visually this
is going to be arguably the best thing
we've ever done I've shown you the
introduction to the different parts that
producer Noah Ferguson has put together
so this is really coming together nicely
but we need 117 more patrons and my goal
is that we could get this done within
the next three to five weeks that's my
goal a hundred and seventeen patrons
really isn't that much right I mean
that's only like 20 new patrons a week
and then we can do it so people please
go to patreon.com/scishow it doesn't
matter how much you contribute this is
totally democratic in that $1,000 pledge
and $1 pledge both count as one one
pledge and we are trying to get 117 more
pledges and I think from what you've
seen are you as bullish about this as I
am that this is going to be fantastic I
mean I'm still developing a sense of
what's going on yes but I'll have to
watch the video clip over a few times
few times to figure it out yeah I think
I'm excited for this tomorrow Pat is
going to prepare for us a an academic
style sort of presentation on his
understanding of the critical thinking
miniseries and yeah we'll have like a 10
or 12 question quiz maybe that will be
released when we hit 2,200 patrons yes
that's right when we hit 2,200 patrons
that's book report on the critical
thinking miniseries is gonna go live so
anyway please make your contributions
patreon.com slash david pakman show
think of this as a real public service
because I think not only would this be
enjoyable for people who are in our core
audience who maybe already understand
the importance of critical thinking
right but putting this out there in the
ether in the in the world I think will
also be a really great thing and yeah
more critical thinking is good yeah if
people are having a conversation and
they hear about I don't know the
difference between validity and so if
something's correct yes they may want to
look that up or a certain logical
fallacy yes not a straw man and
conversation gotta find that on YouTube
right it will be very useful during
those thanksgiving or i guess what
holidays are upcoming Passover and
Easter are upcoming during those
discussions where your crazy uncle
starts making wildly fallacious
political claims
you will be armed with an
epistemological structure with which you
can call into question their beliefs and
there's nothing that says holidays and
heartwarming family time together then
making the conservative people that go
to your holiday events look and feel as
though they know absolutely nothing
about what's going on in the world
that's really what my holiday support is
about for me yeah no doubt about it that
and vegan turkey but I'm speaking for
Pat on on that front okay let's take a
break we have a lot more coming up for
you on today's program